is Tony Hawk a good skater again a
matter of opinion I would say if I had
to judge myself I'm very good for my age
all right is Tony Hawk a vegetarian I am
not a vegetarian I do lean towards
plant-based Foods my friend said it best
was and he said um hey Tony I know you
kind of lean towards vegetarianism but I
bet you took a mistake and he's right I
would I love barbecue too all right it's
Tony Hawk a boomer I am not a boomer I
am Gen X my older siblings are boomers
and you know what's funny is somehow
this is an insult it only means that you
are part of the baby boomer generation
and that was the generation of families
that came back from the war and then
everyone was having babies that is what
the baby boomer generation is people
there's your lesson in Generations I was
born in 1968 not Boomer